well I think a good husband for one
thing yes depend on having a good wife
and I was lucky enough to choose the
right woman and we were married more
than 64 years ago
Rosa and I have learned a few things
first of all we give each other plenty
of space we don't try to encroach on the
private affairs off each other the Rosen
has our own major commitment so outside
the home and so do I we cooperate
whenever we can we share delightful
aspects of life like fly-fishing and
bird-watching and things of that kind
and also we've made the commitment then
large number of years ago not able to go
to sleep at night estranged if we do
have some arguments to in a day we have
almost a commitment before God that will
resolve that argument before we go to
sleep so I think those are the reasons
we've been able to enjoy each other's
company all this time